( intro music )
Onkuri: Government agencies in
many parts of the world
either don't know much about
the problem of
wildlife trafficking
or they might be understaffed,
they might be under-trained,
they might be under-equipped.
So, we go in to help them and
supplement their efforts.
We give them
investigation training
we sometimes act as decoy buyers
to help them gather
evidence that they need.
This is a
typical seizure.
Each one those little blue bags
contains one balled-up pangolin.
A typical seizure can have
anything from 50-200 animals
and they are transported
under extraordinarily
unhygienic and
inhuman conditions.
They're just balled-up
and stuffed into boxes.
They may be, you
know, half-starved
and certainly dehydrated by the
time they reach the market.
Then to increase their
body weight
they are force-fed flour
and sometimes even cement
just so they can
make more money.
Another trade we worked
on was the exotic pet trade.
This is a fairly typical
tourist night spot where
these people walk around
and they ask tourists
to take pictures
with slow lorises.
These animals are all
poached from the wild
and their teeth
are yanked out
so they don't bite
the tourists.
And when we were working
with the police team on this
one of my colleagues who doesn't
always do investigations
she asked me,
"Do you not sometimes
feel bad about what
you are doing?"
In the sense that you are
gaining the trust of
these traffickers.
Obviously they like you and
they talk to you nicely
and then you get them arrested.
And I thought about it
and I realized that
no, I don't feel bad for them.
- ( audience laughter )
- ( applause )
That's because...
That's because once
you go undercover
and you start talking to them
you realize they feel
nothing for these animals.
One of the traffickers we
talked to, she told us
about how she would smuggle
baby slow lorises.
She would put them
in little boxes
little cardboard boxes and put
all those cardboard boxes
inside a big suitcase
to send by air.
The animals were sedated.
And she told me that if
all the animals survive
then obviously she was
giving them too much air
and she could cram in a
few more the next time.
But if less than half survive,
then she would consider
putting them in slightly
larger cardboard boxes.